Learn more at tempurpedic.com
♪
BRIAN: ALL RIGHT, NEW YORK CITY
RESTAURANT OWNERS ARE FIGHTING
BACK BIG TIME AGAINST MAYOR
BLAPSZ RIDICULOUS VACCINE
MANDATE.
OUR NEXT GUEST SUED DE BLASIO
OVER THE INDOOR DINING BAN BACK
IN DECEMBER AND IS TAKING ACTION
AGAIN.
IRENE THE OPENER OF THE FAMOUS
KELLOGG’S DINER IN BROOKLYN AND
JOINS US NOW.
IRENE, NOW THEY WANT YOU TO SHOW
A VACCINE CARD.
>> GOOD MORNING.
BRIAN: IF YOU GOT CAUGHT WITH
SOMEONE EATING YOUR RESTAURANT
WITH A WITHOUT A VACCINE CARD
1,000 BUCKS.
SECOND TIME 2,000 BUCKS.
HOW DO YOU FEEL ABOUT THAT?
>> I FEEL THAT MY LIBERTIES ARE
BEEN TAKEN AWAY FROM ME.
MY CIVIL LIBERTIES HAVE BEEN
TAKEN AWAY FROM ME.
I FEEL LIKE I DON’T HAVE THE
RIGHT TO FEED MY CHILDREN.
I FEEL FEAR THAT -- THIS MAYOR
HAS JUST PUT DANGER IN MY LIFE.
HE IS CREATING DIVISION.
AND HE IS GOING TO CREATE
VIOLENCE.
THIS IS NOT GOING TO BE GOOD.
BRIAN: YOU TOLD ME THAT, YOU
KNOW, YOU SAW IT IN PEOPLE’S
EYES.
THEY DON’T WANT TO BE ASKED
ABOUT THEIR HEALTH, THEIR
VACCINE STATUS.
AND YOU HAVE TO BE ON THE
FRONTLINES?
WHAT’S THE REACTION YOU ARE
GETTING FROM THE PEOPLE IN
BROOKLYN?
>> SO, THE STARE, THE STARE AT
THE DOOR IS PUTTING FEAR IN ME.
I JUST -- I FEEL IT AND ONE
PERSON ACTUALLY SAID TO ME YOU
BETTER NOT REFUSE SERVICE TO ME.
IT SHOOK ME.
THIS IS EXACTLY WHAT I’M AFRAID
OF.
AND OUR MAYOR REALLY THINKS IN
HIS COMMENTED DEMENTED MIND IS H
SOMETHING GOOD HERE.
HE’S NOT.
HE IS GOING TO CREATE MORE
VIOLENCE.
IS HE GOING TO CREATE MORE CRIME
WITH THIS.
HE IS TAKING AWAY PEOPLE’S
LIBERTIES.
BRIAN: YOU ARE SUING, CORRECT?
>> I HAVE TO.
I HAVE TO.
BRIAN: TOUGH PAY FOR A LAWYER
AND YOU ARE SUING THE CITY.
>> CORRECT.
WE’RE SUING THE CITY.
WE’RE SUING MAYOR de BLASIO
BECAUSE HE IS -- HE IS NOT
LETTING ME RUN MY BUSINESS WITH
ALL THE RIGHTS THAT I HAVE.
YOU KNOW, I ALREADY HAVE A
1.4 MILLION JUDGMENT AGAINST ME
FROM THE FIRST MANDATES THAT OUR
GOVERNOR AND OUR MAYOR PUT ON
US, THE FIRST TIME AROUND.
AND NOW THIS?
THEY ARE BREAKING ME.
THAT’S EXACTLY WHAT THEY ARE
DOING.
STEVE: DON’T LET THEM.
AND YOU ARE TAKING ACTION.
>> I’M A MOM OF FOUR KIDS, TOO.
I’M NOT COMPLYING, BRIAN.
BRIAN: IRENE, I’M GOING TO HAVE
TO LEAVE IT THERE.
CONTINUE TO COME HERE.
I’M SO GLAD YOU ARE TAKING
ACTION BECAUSE NOW THE CLIPBOARD
POLICE ARE GOING TO COME UP TO
YOU AND START HITTING FINES WITH
YOU AND LET THEM DEAL WITH THE
CUSTOMERS.
THE OWNER OF KELLOGG’S DINER
FIND A WAY TO GET DOWN THERE AND
PATRONIZE THAT PLACE.
IRENE, THANKS SO MUCH.
>> THANK YOU, BRIAN.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
BRIAN: YOU GOT IT.
WE REACHED OUT TO MAYOR de
BLASIO’S OFFICE FOR COMMENT.